[Music]
thanks for being here i am great how are
you i had a great holiday and uh what
did you do for the holidays uh we
nothing it was this big rebellion it was
like what
let's do how about we do nothing because
did you even make the big meal did you
make no
oh that's borderline depressed
and moved i know it was slightly i did
nothing i stayed in bed and cried
close uh no i did i slept in really late
and then uh we did end up going over to
a friend's pretty much to mooch
thanksgiving dinner at the end we're
like hold on jane's cooking and um and
she she was nice enough to cook us but
we have a huge i have a huge family
situation happening for the christmas
holidays now what happens do they do
they come here do you have do you have a
family that visits you in los angeles
yes i do okay
what's wrong with that
they might be watching so yeah my mom's
gonna be like why did you why are you
talking about us like that no my mom
comes and i have a brother lives here
and i've got a sister at back east my
mother and stepfather regularly come and
they have a a mobile not a mobile home
it feels like a mobile home um it's uh
an rv so they usually come with the the
durango and the and the dogs they bring
on rv to los angeles yeah
tell me specifically where you live but
don't tell them but uh
where what area we talked about where i
am in my neighborhood they won't let
them park there there's like an
ordinance like sorry there's no rvs it's
like the beverly hillbillies so
they have to go to rv park but when i
first moved here i lived in this tiny
little house in the hills and it was
literally up a dirt road but they
managed to bring that rv all the way up
that dirt and it's massive this thing is
like you know it's like a school bus
yeah i've seen those things yeah and i
had i had a tiny house but i had highly
coveted parking spaces up off of a dirt
road it was literally trail it was a
trail and they went up there and they
plugged it in
and they parked all across these three
parking spaces kind of hung out in the
road i got many neighbors were mad and
then they blew out my entire electrical
fuse box like they
probably the whole neighborhood too yeah
yeah they're like are they coming again
with the rv this time oddly they're
leaving it at home i'm like wait
why i kind of love it i mean they
they're obsessed with it they don't they
go camping they never out they and they
they park it in their driveway sometimes
and camp there they did this one time
wait a minute
we're gonna park and we're not leaving
but we're gonna have a vacation in the
driveway in the rv we're like
my brother and i were like really okay
well you're the one that stayed in bed
crying for thanksgiving so i don't think
you have it seems like a family trait
now let's go camping and everyone just
goes right to the driveway
it just hangs out in the rv we're gonna
get away but we can't get away so we're
gonna go i was like all right this is
like it's like when i was a little kid
and with like the neighbors down the
street had a pool and i was like i want
to go swimming there my mom's like just
fill up the bathtub with cold water and
wear your bathing suit it's the same
thing
get in the cold bathtub
they're going to talk to you about this
interview you know this is going to get
back to them oh it's so over already my
mom tell us about your christmas tree
christmas tree it's a pile of sand
no it's
we have a flaw everyone's descending on
us for christmas so yeah it'll be fun